ZACH LIEBERMAN: Most people
think about art as objects,
that you put
something in a gallery
like a sculpture or a painting.
But for us, art is systems,
that we're creating systems.
[music playing]
AR, it's almost like a layer
of magic on top of the reality.
I would say that we
are artists that work
with software and hardware.
We work with technology, but
to make artistic expression.
[music playing]
MOLMOL KOU: He asked me to
work on the project with him,
and for some reason,
he always asked me
to work on a project at a bar.
[laughing]
And the project never
happened, but, you know.
I personally love
things I can touch.
So I love working with
hardware, I love electronics,
I have a lot of
patience with debugging
like, hardware problem.
And Zach is kind
of the contrary,
he is really good at software,
and software debugging.
When there's an
integration coming in,
we both are doing
kind of what we like.
I really want to find a
way to visualize emotions,
so other people can understand
how a person is feeling.
And to have some
kind of empathy,
if they can see the
emotions being visualized.
So this app actually
visualize your speech
based on the volume, and
how many words you speak,
and how fast you speak it.
And it's almost like
an audio visualization
turned into a mask.
The app covers your face.
[vocalizing]
ZACH LIEBERMAN: Really
like to do weird stuff,
especially with the face.
Like, cut parts of the face,
take the eyes, extend them out.
Like really, kind of play
with the face, and then
use that almost
as a kind of mask.
Like, take your left
and your right eye,
create a crown of
them around your head,
and then use that to
hide your identity.
We've been experimenting
a lot with space, using
AR to put things in 3D space.
Like put images, or
video, or sound, and type
was a natural progression
in those experimentations.
What does it mean to
put words in space?
So Weird Type is an AR app that
you can install on your phone,
and it allows you to
write text, and then
place that text in 3D space.
So that you can write a
message, and you can place it,
and as you move, the type
can change or animate.
But it really is like
floating in the air.
Molmol and I have just been
experimenting and playing
with AR, and making these weird
expressions in the studio,
and posting them online.
It's so nice to actually have
something that we can give
to people, that people can try,
and they can have the same sort
of joy that we've been having.
So these technologies
are already out there.
Face tracking, you know, these
computer vision techniques,
these machine learning
techniques, they are out there.
And what we're trying to
do is appropriate them
and use them for artistic,
for creative expression,
and also to suggest we can use
them in completely different
ways, and ways that
governments are not intending,
and companies are not intending.
But artists can sort of suggest
different possible futures.
[music playing]